it's graduation season and did you know
that some of your favorite stars don't
just have Beauty but they have brains
too I've got the proof hey i'm danny
director with ET now check out these
celebrity Smarties
emma watson is a star on the big screen
and in the classroom the Harry Potter
star just graduated from Brown
University with the degree in English
she told Elmo zine in April 2014 so many
people told me it was impossible I kept
saying I don't care this is what I want
and graduating will for me be very
symbolic of all of that and Cody Simpson
has brains and talent the Dancing with
the Stars contestant was the
valedictorian of his high school class
in Atlanta Georgia
it's what's he and ladies if you want to
impress Cody you better study up well
it's always Mayim Bialik doesn't only
play a neuro scientist on the Big Bang
Theory compared to the real-world
applications of neurobiology theoretical
physics is what's the word I'm looking
for
she's won in real life to the actress
got her PhD from UCLA in 2007 and
speaking of life imitating art
Kenji young was actually a doctor before
you guys big break and knocked up where
he played you guessed it a doctor
congratulations to you and of course we
can't talk about smart celebs without
mentioning James Franco the
oscar-nominated actor has a degree from
UCLA I've studied at NYU and Columbia
and is currently a PhD candidate for
comparative literature at Yale and if
that's not enough James is also a
professor he's teaching screenplay
writing and directing at USC UCLA NYU
and Columbia wow that guy wears a lot of
hats hey i'm janie director for ET now
you